so in the last video we did Godzilla
took Superman to the Woodshed and gave
him the beating of a Lifetime well
Godzilla does a whole lot more than that
so this initially opens up with
Supergirl and she's really important
here right bear with me here for a
second it has to do with Supergirl now
like flash shows up at iron Height's
prison basically fighting what looks
like cthulu who's a spider I have no
idea who this guy is we're going to call
him cthulu but like flash is absolutely
kind of not really having his powers and
the reason why is because like there's
this Mist which basically slows him down
and would you know all the villains in
Iron Heights just decide to take this
moment to basically orchestrate a prison
break which is exactly what I would do
but because the flash is slower than he
normally is they just start beating the
crap out of the guy because you know
when you're the fastest man alive
nothing says weakness like gas and so
basically Supergirl shows up on the
scene uses her ability to blow air and
then Saves The Flash and the villains
are more or less taken care of here's a
kicker to all of this right while she's
there with Green Lantern she's suddenly
realizes she says Cel and she's like I
can't hear his heartbeat and Green
Lantern's like what and she's like I can
always hear his heartbeat always but
it's stopped and they're like no there's
no way Superman's Dead son son son
Godzilla in the last video we did it
turns out Godzilla killed
Superman how crazy is that right so then
you transition in New York right
Superman's lifeless body is just laying
there you got Billy bats and Shazam
standing over him just like my God and
then Adam Smasher shows up now here's
the thing right Adam Smasher the guy's
very similar to like giant man from
Marvel Comics right like his strength
and so on increases proportionately with
his size this guy decides he wants to go
toe-to-toe with Godzilla you know what
Godzilla says you know what Godzilla
says y'all Godzilla says man son you
better come strong dude he whips that
tail sends that dude flying now the
guy's trying to hold his own as best he
can right props to him props to this guy
he's doing what he can where he can but
it is Adam Smasher right like this guy
sucks so this dude just gets absolutely
crushed Haw girl shows up to like help
Billy Batson out it's like we got to get
Superman out of here right like we we
need to do something we got to get this
guy going right get him to safety
something because they have no idea the
fact that he's dead as far as they're
concerned he's just unconscious because
Godzilla just gave him the Beatdown of a
lifetime but then while Billy Batson is
watching all of this he's like yeah
we'll we'll try to help I'll try to
offer some kind of a distraction he
looks up just in time to see Godzilla
kill Adam Smasher Godzilla man dude he's
he's leaving no crumbs you know what I
mean like he's just taking it to him so
at that point Billy's just like okay
this guy's killing the Justice League
right like this guy's got to go so he's
like I'll distract it get Superman out
of here and she and hul girl is like I'm
not going to leave you and it's like
dude if you don't get out of here man
like he's like this is all my fault I
have to fix it Yad yaad y now here's the
thing man one of the things to know
about Billy Batson right Billy Batson
this dude slept on right like people
don't realize like comic book fans know
all about Billy Batson but for non-comic
book readers they're just like yeah
Zachary Levi who's pissed off because uh
James gun's brother gets to be in the
movies and Zachary Levi might get the
boot right quit being jealous so the
thing about it is like he's a guy that
people don't really realize is as
capable as he is the reality here is
that Shazam depending on who's writing
the story every bit of strong as
Superman right sometimes stronger if he
decides to invoke magic in a fight with
Superman right this kid calls down the
lightning right Shazam right brings
Godzilla down or at least offers a
distraction he's like get Superman out
of here I'll lure the monster out of the
city he's like but first it's time for a
little bit of Revenge right they
absolutely punch the crap out of
Godzilla send this dude flying across
the city into a whole bunch of buildings
killing a bunch of innocent people
because the Justice League don't care
about the lives of the citizens in their
own City so what you do is you
transition back over to like the flash
who's kind of doing his thing because
the reality is when Supergirl and Green
Lantern took off they just left him
there right they were just like we got
to go right and just bolted directly for
superman but because all the villains
were orchestrating a prison break right
like the Rogues like Captain Cold and
all these guys launch their attack
against the flash they just kind of
momentarily freeze them and then they
start going after Green Lantern who's
kind of recovered back at the scene and
then of course you switch over to Wonder
Woman and Donna Troy who are basically
dealing with a giant William Mammoth
nobody cares so what you do here is you
jump to Oliver creen the Green Arrow but
one of the things to remember is that
all of this happened because Lex Luther
and his guys messing with
interdimensional travel ended up jumping
to an alternate reality where you had
all these Titans that we know Godzilla
King Kong the whole nine yards and
inadvertently brought them into the main
DC Universe now is interesting and cool
as Green Arrow is all those little quips
and all that kind of stuff this guy is
just painfully unprepared to face off
against any of these Titans the guy's
got no real Powers he's got awesome
arrows and he can do some cool stuff
there's not a whole lot he can do here
he's watching King Kong right King Kong
the Beast right he's watching this guy
just dominating all these Titans and
while it is interesting to see the
reality is the best that he can do is
just Flee for his life and even in the
ensuing chaos just like collateral
damage right like bodies hitting the
floor and so on and so forth Oliver
Queen is just sent flying now Supergirl
does show up here and initially she goes
to talk to King Kong and we know how
King Kong has a thing for White Chicks
she's like I mean no harm to you but you
must back away from my friend and King
Kong just kind of looks at her for a
second and she's like Oliver move to a
safe distance I don't know how this is
going to go and King Kong's just kind of
interested in it right as soon as he
goes to touch her she's like no right
and just punches this guy right just
like punches him in the face but here's
the thing man it ain't like when they
hit Godzilla son it ain't like when they
hit Godzilla and like they said that guy
flying King Kong's just like don't do
that that's literally all it is right he
just like wipes his face and he's just
like don't do that and so like she's
absolutely pummeling King Kong right so
literally it's Supergirl versus King
Kong which is kind of cool I think we're
all just kind of waiting for the giant
fight that happens when King Kong fights
Godzilla but then you jump to Gotham
City right now here's the thing so like
Batman and Batwoman along with uh Dina
right like Black Canary and iPhone
they're kind of having this conversation
Batman says the heart rate dampening
device is effectively keeping the
creature sedated right it's kind of a
stop Gap until they can figure out what
it is that they're going to do but the
big question that's asked here really by
Black Canary but kind of everybody as a
whole is where did they come from and
why are they rampaging in cities and the
whole idea is well not really entirely
sure it all kind of seems to be a little
murky we'll have to try to get an answer
to this but Billy Batson shows up and
says it's actually my fault I screwed up
which it kind of is right there's a
little bit more going on behind the
scenes and we'll cover that as we get
further through the story but Billy
basson is just kind of like yeah I kind
of goofed uh I was just trying to help
right he's kind of the one that screwed
everything up what's going on behind the
scenes is him talking to the rest of the
Justice League and saying Superman is
dead right I was just trying to help
that's where I screwed up that's why
it's my fault because they didn't know
what he was talking about right they
were just kind of like what's your fault
right and he's like Superman's death and
the first thing cyborg says is we have
to tell Lois right what does Batman say
no we do not tell Lois Lane right we
cannot tell Lois Lane do not say that he
is not dead right there's no way he can
be the response Batman here nobody says
a word to Lois not until I see Clark now
if you know Batman comics effectively
right if you know Batman comics well
enough what Batman is basically saying
here is this almost kind of like a
subliminal message to Godzilla right
Godzilla of course can't hear it and
it's really just kind of him speaking
metaphorically do you guys know what it
is a Batman saying do you guys know what
Batman's saying here's exactly what
Batman's saying it's like El pridor said
back in the day right Godzilla didn't
beat Superman he just pissed him off and
now he's because when Superman
comes back he's going to be out for
blood with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end if you
guys need to get caught up make sure you
click this link to the last video and I
will catch you all later peace